alors à 6 ans j'étais mal dans ma peau
ça peut paraître prématuré pour des
problématiques
elle j'avais cette sensation de
ressembler à un homme et disait
régulièrement à ma mère que je ne me
trouvais pas joli elle a pensé qu une
psy pourrait nous apporter de l'aide et
en effet elle a apaisé mais d'angoise
mais à l'adolescence j'ai recommencé à
ressentir un véritable mal-être
j'étais mal dans ma peau les garçons ne
me remarque est pas ils n'en avaient que
pour les filles populaire du bahut qui
avec leurs tenues ostentatoire genre
string qui dépasse mettait tout le monde
d'accord
alors j'ai eu une obsession à cette
époque ressembler à toutes ces filles me
maquiller comme un camion volé est
évidemment portée des stream pour
attirer leurs à 30 leur attention
j'étais grosse du moins je me sentais
grosse pleine de boutons d'acné et avec
un énorme déficit de confiance en moi
j'ai alors tout fait pour perdre du
poids
masquer un visage que je trouvais
hideuse et transformer une apparence qui
ne me convenait pas sans trop de succès
mais en cours de 5e
je suis monté sur l'estrade devant mes
camarades pour chanter et le garçon dont
j'étais alors follement ma amoureusement
en fait remarquer j'ai alors compris que
pour plaire je n'avais pas l'atout que
de mon physique
j'avais aussi des talents que je me suis
mis en tête d'aller découvrir
c'est ainsi que je suis devenu délégué
de classe chanteuse dans la chorale et
j'ai enfin réussi à pécho il est des
danois il s'appelait sebastian et ce
premier roulage de pelle fut déterminant
dans la construction de femmes
non je plaisante en fait c'était gluant
maladroit mais sam a au moins prouvé que
j'étais capable de plaire parce que
qu'est-ce que plaire finalement car la
seule chose qui avait changé à l'époque
c'était le regard que je porte sur moi
c'est pour ça que je suis devant vous ce
soir car depuis cet instant je n'ai
cessé d'investiguer d'apprendre à me
faire à me connaître et d'apprendre à me
faire confiance à 19 ans j'ai signé un
cdi en tant que journaliste à 20 ans
je suis devenue directrice d'antenne
d'une web radio sur les médecines
naturelles et le développement personnel
radio médecines douces qui s'est classé
dans les années qui ont suivi 13e web
radio de france à 24 ans j'ai créé un
concept de soirée interactive appelé les
soirées sans ces expériences où l'idée
est de faire expérimenter un public des
outils thérapeutiques et à l'âge de 27
ans j'ai publié mon tout premier ouvrage
aux éditions larousse qui porte ce titre
de c'est décidé je mets pouze et qui
relate cette prise de conscience et
m'amener à vous ce soir
tant qu'on ne se rencontrent pas qu'on
n'apprend pas à se connaître on reste
bloqué sur une image superficielle de
soi même on se gâche la vie des années
pour des complexes que personne ne
remarque à part nouveau on se rend la
vie impossible pour des détails
insignifiants et des imperfections qui
lorsqu'on sait les aimer nous offre tout
notre charme l'amour de soi et d'un
sujet qui n'est ni compris ni intégrés
qui ose dire qu'ils s'aiment passe pour
vaniteux suffisant ou un bus lui-même
par contre maintenir les être en
situation de victimisation valoriser les
manques encourager les dépendances pour
ça notre société est excellent on va
quand même pas donné un levier d'action
aux gens pour transformer leur vie pour
réaliser leurs rêves pour devenir acteur
une vie non pas parfaite mais
épanouissante et bien moi aussi
ce soir j'ai décidé de vous révéler le
secret qui permet de transformer votre
vie pour le meilleur
choisissez vous n'attendez plus
remettez vous au centre de votre
histoire n'attendez pas de vous aimer
pour vous choisir n'attendez pas d'avoir
une vie parfaite un compte en banque
remplit le bon poids sur la balance la
personne idéale dans votre vie fait
alliance avec vous même apprenez à vous
découvrir et vous répondre et vous
réinventer en dehors de tous vos
conditionnement croyances et projections
apprenez à vous aimer tels que vous êtes
aussi imparfait merveilleux que
pathétique
apprenez à découvrir vos multiples
talents passait des qualités afin de les
mettre au service du monde
prenez en charge vos souffrances afin de
ne pas les faire peser sur les autres
devenait enfin cette personne que vous
avez toujours rêvé rêvé d'être en vous
autorisant être audacieux fragile et
puissant courageux et apeurés nous
sommes des êtres contradictoires et
bourré de manquements mais nous sommes
également unique et exceptionnel sur ce
chemin de l'amour de soi
eh bien j'ai voulu prendre des
métaphores afin de le rendre concret le
mariage on fait partie j'ai repensé à
tous qui m'avez manqué dans mes
histoires d'amour passée et j'ai
commencé à me l'offrir du soin de
l'attention de l'ecoute du respect de la
présence de la surprise
j'ai pris en charge la dépendance
affective et mon besoin vital de
reconnaissance
j'ai également compris que l'amour de
soi et notre engagement fondateur et
quelle image de toutes nos relations
avec les autres il faudra nourrir à
entretenir ce lien notre bien-être avec
nous-mêmes n'est jamais acquis il faudra
régulièrement raviver la flamme
ça peut paraître schizophrène à certains
moments mais c'est véritablement
passionnant et j'ai pris conscience que
nous sommes la personne avec laquelle
nous allons passer le plus de temps
jusqu'à la fin de nos jours
autant faire du voyage un moment
agréable la vie ne sera jamais un long
fleuve tranquille
et tant mieux tu expliques on faire
autant d'intérêt mais pour résister aux
intempéries
il vous faudra un abri solide
accueillant et aimant dans lequel vous
pourrez certaines fois accueillir
d'autres armes pour en prendre soin
apprendre à mémé m'a offert un refuge
non pas un échappatoire
car depuis que je m'aime je n'ai jamais
autant ressenti d'amour pour les autres
pour cette vie et pour cette humanité
alors si vous le voulez bien je crois
qu'il n'y a pas juste de l'amour il est
surtout des preuves d'amour j'avais
envie de vous faire expérimenter ce que
c'est juste
de sentir en amour alors je vous invite
et peut-être à vous redresser à vous
asseoir
voilà un peu plus un peu plus droit
c'est le moment on va vibrer alors je
vais vous inviter à fermer les yeux
l'espace de quelques instants et a posé
une main sur le coeur je voulais c'est
repenser un moment le dernier moment de
votre vie où vous avez ressenti de
l'amour c'était peut-être hier lorsque
vous avez couché vos enfants c'était
tout à l'heure quand vous avez embrassé
la personne que vous aimez c'est
peut-être en raccrochant avec votre mère
il ya à peine une heure reconnecter vous
à cette sensation d'amour
laissez-la vous envahir
maintenant vous vous laisser circuler
l'amour en vous j'ai envie de vous faire
penser à une partie de vous que vous
rejetez avec lequel vous n'êtes pas en
paix peut-être que c'est un aspect
physique
un trait de votre personnalité une
partie de votre histoire peut-être des
erreurs qui n'en sont pas vraiment pensé
à une part de vous même avec laquelle
vous aimeriez enfin être en paix et je
vais vous inviter à diffuser tout
l'amour
il peut vous habitez et à reconnaître
apprécier chaque partie de vous toutes
les parties de nous mérite l'amour
alors au bout de 3 vous pourrez réouvrir
les jeux et cette fois-ci peut-être
poser un regard différent sur le monde
peut-être justement un regard plus
amoureux un regard plus ouvert un regard
de compassion de bienveillance 1 2 et 3
vous savez quoi j'ai compris que dans la
vie c'est pas les événements en tant que
tel qui vont compter c'est vraiment le
regard qu'on va poser dessus
aimez vous ai aimés être vous l'amour et
le plus incroyable des exhausteurs de
goût de l'existence sous amour tout
change
c'est la meilleure des drogues mais des
ans partout et en excès et surtout
faites en profiter les autres
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]